Melissa Gilbert says goodbye to her  breast implants hey guys I'm Sarah  Flanagan in the Little House on the  Prairie stars sassy and candid blogpost  is what's trending on ET now the 50 year  old actress tweeted about the procedure  Tuesday but it's something she's  actually been thinking about for years  in her blog post Melissa says appearing  on Dancing with the Stars in 2012  seriously affected her body image  Melissa said competing on the show put  her obsession with her looks at an  all-time high  writing quote it was all about spray tan  and glitter and glamour and what other  people think and being skinny way too  skinny yuck  the actor says she experience body  scrutiny at a young age reading that  while appearing on Little House on the  Prairie she was made to wear a padded  bra to read more from Alyssa's blog post  check out ET online bye guys